you've criticized the famed Putin critic
Alexi navalny
what's the nature of your criticism well
this hasn't really been a kind of a
criticism in the way that you know
people have implied but more just
reminding people that navalny isn't some
stooge of the West as other people have
you know kind of depicted him in the in
the Russian firm but you know saying
that this is kind of you know he's
pro-western he's he's a Russian
nationalist
and a Russian Patriot you know in the
past uh he's articulated you know things
are not sort of dissimilar from some of
the people around Putin and it's more
just reminding people that you know just
because you kind of see somebody
you know as a kind of an opposition
figure or somebody who might be more
palatable from you know your perspective
looking from the West
they're not always going to be you know
what you think they are now Alex is a
Russian and you know in a particular
Russian context he's different from
Putin
but he wouldn't necessarily you know
kind of run you know the Russian system
in words that we were like
so that's it's kind of it's not a kind
of a criticism it's more of a critique
of the way that we look at things you
know I think it's a mistake to always
you know say oh this is pro-western or
this is a you know liberal I mean what
does that mean pro-western I mean he's a
Russian he's a Russian Nationalist and a
Russian Patriot and he's often you know
been you know quite critical about
immigration
um he's had some negative views about
you know one part remember said don't
feed the caucuses you know kind of
played upon some of the you know the
racial and ethnic tensions inside of you
know Russia itself as well now he is a
pluralist and then he's kind of and he
wants to have you know different uh
set of political actors there but he
also isn't promoting Revolution he's not
Lenin he's not wanting to bring down the
state
he wants to kind of you know change
the people who were in charge that's
what he's being best to be focused on
and you know he might have
and have things done do things that you
know we elsewhere might not like and I
guess the bigger picture there is
it's not trivial to know that if you
place another human in power
uh to replace the current human and
power that things are going to be better
they could be a lot worse because
there's a momentum to a system a system
is bigger than just this leader even
when that leader has a huge amount of
power that's absolutely right and you
know he grew up in that you know same
system now he's younger than Putin so
he's got a different generational
perspective
and he's not wedded to the Soviet Union
uh or you know kind of some concept of
the Russian Empire he doesn't seem to
spend a lot of time I don't know what
he's doing you know in jail but he's
probably not sitting around you know
reading romanosov and you know the kind
of a great kind of tracks of Russian
history could be actually but I mean I
think you know navalny has a different
worldview on a different perspective
just like Medved if was different you
know in his time in presidency in mid
some you know changes and some
Innovations there but don't think that
they're going to be radically different
because look Gorbachev I mean he was
so different from andropov and chilienko
now this is the person
but he was also constrained by the
system and he wanted to have change but
he wanted evolutionary change he didn't
know how to do it but he didn't want to
bring the whole system down look a crush
off when he came in you know after that
whole period of
you know everybody's trying to figure
out what to do after Stalin had died and
it was all this kind of back and forth
and eventually Kristoff emerges and you
know he tries to make changes to the
system but he's also a creature of a
very specific context he's grown up in
the same system and he you know kind of
brings all kinds of elements of chaos
there into the whole thing and you know
gets into a standoff of the United
States
that we know is the Cuban Missile Crisis
and eventually you know gets removed you
know we're looking at what's happening
in the United Kingdom right now you know
they've just churned through three
uh Prime Ministers and actually five
prime ministers in you know kind of as
many years but all of those prime
ministers have come out of the context
of the conservative party in the whole
you know kind of just shades of you know
the same thing they've all come out of
the same academic and you know kind of
privileged backgrounds even uh Rishi
sunak the new um prime minister is the
first you know Indian or anglo-indian uh
prime minister and British history it
was a kind of phenomenal you know kind
of as a child of in Indian immigrants
but also um
a person of great privilege from the
same academic and party background as
the others you know so there are always
differences with those human beings but
those contexts matter a lot